so today i'm going to talk about
agile analytics applications with hadoop
my name is russell journey i am a data
scientist i live in pacifica
a little bit about me this is uh like
last year the year before
is uh world bearding champion i'm trying
to beat this guy
bearding is my natural talent i
discovered
i'm probably better at it than anything
else
i'm going to be giving away uh a few
copies of uh
agile data science the book for good
questions afterwards so pay attention
uh there's a if you use this code at
o'reilly off d you get like 50
off
so we go fast but don't worry if you
google me on the hortonworks and data
syndrome blogs there are examples for
like everything we cover
with code on github
so in terms of application development
building web apps is a fairly mature
venture at this point like since rails
happen there all these post rails
frameworks
and you can use an agile methodology and
set out to build a web app and have a
pretty good chance of building something
that's going to be useful to someone
it's a pretty mature field
then you have data warehousing where you
have data warehouses that satisfy
business intelligence requirements but
they tend to be fragmented
so you can never get at the data you
need there tend to be very complicated
processes to get like new tables added
or
to do the joins you want to do so data
tends to be segmented
and then you've got high performance
computing or scientific computing
that's univac and that's deep blue they
sort of have similar architectures and
look the same
they're both warehouse scale machines
just of different eras
this is like mpi globus smart kid-only
technologies i tried to use them like in
college
and i couldn't figure them out like word
count was really hard
and so you might define data science as
the intersection of these three fields
so now we've got these warehouse scale
machines but it turns out it's very hard
to utilize them
at scale all the different commodity
machines together
because of the disparities in speed and
capacity of local ram local disk and
network
and so like hadoop to the rescue it's
really easy to use especially
as compared to like mpi and these other
platforms and frameworks
there's pig there's hive there's
cascading it's high level
interfaces it's incredibly cheap it's
about one percent of the cost to use
network attached storage as compared to
network attached storage or a
storage area network because it's local
disk
and so an apartment can buy its own
hadoop cluster without having to get
like
overhead approval and so what you end up
doing is dumping all your data from all
the data marts and data warehouses and
applications into one place
how you performs this data lake uh so
you start doing joins that you've never
been able to do before
people become nocturnal that way you can
have the hadoop cluster all to yourself
it's a pretty sweet thing you do all
kinds of etl
you have an army of mappers and
producers at your command
so once you've got this now what what
new opportunities does this expose
and so it's the analytics application
which is to provide
insight make predictions predict the
future
so to build these things it's a very
broad skill set from
customer representative through marketer
product manager
interaction experience designer web
developer or hardcore researcher
nobody has all those skills so um they
told us this in film class
making analytics applications is
inherently collaborative
so it's a team effort no matter what
and so a data science team ideally
composed of three to four people
if you have more than this communication
overhead tends to override
and start to be very costly
you can have expert researchers in your
organization and
you can sort of use them as resources
and whatnot but you generally want
t-shaped or generalists on a data
science team
treat it like a creative studio not an
assembly line
where you uh you do have hardcore
deadlines and requirements though
so what you want to do with an analytics
application is get insight into a
product
um but how do you do that so this back
end now has gotten really thick
hadoop is this entire other thing
that sits behind your database so
gener and generating insight uh that
people would pay for in an analytics
application could take like 10 to 100
even more time compared to uh scanning
that application
you know for the web and so there's this
timeline disjoint
of doing analytics or hardcore research
with data
versus building agile web apps or mobile
apps
and so how do you ship insights
efficiently
how do you collaborate on these two
different timelines the research
timeline versus the application
development timeline
so there's definitely a wrong way to do
it and that's to kind of bolt it on
to your existing process where it's like
oh we made this great design
your job is to predict the future for it
you're a data scientist
day one hey what's taking you song to
reliably predict the future
okay well you made a really accurate
model but the users don't understand
what 86 percent true means
this would have come up on flightcaster
a lot your flight is 86
on time i sort of understand that it's
like
inference but like my mom definitely
doesn't get that
and is angry whether the fight is on
time or late depending on what she
expects
so you're freaking out and the plane has
hit the mountain
kind of reminds me of the waterfall
model of software engineering
that we all got away from because it
didn't succeed very very often
and so there's a big problem you can't
design insight in analytics applications
you can't specify this up front
it doesn't work that way you have to
discover insight
and you discover by exploring
so that we might formulate a strategy
that's to make an application for
exploring your data
where you iterate and publish
intermediate results
and that becomes a palette for what you
ship whether it's an application or a
system
or an api
and so there's this concept of data
design that takes into account the fact
that it's never the first query it's the
15th to the 150th at
2 am that gets those aha moments
and it's slow to do those in batch and
any system with large amount of data
they tend not to be instant
but more than that if you had a sql
prompt and you do have a big data
warehouse and you can query it
the context of the insights that that
produces is not very good
as compared to like a web application
that's properly contextualized for the
user experience that you're after
so it's it's actually easy to also
invest uh
man years in the wrong statistical
models where you define a problem
slightly off
and you have a researcher that does
exactly what you asked and in the end
you get very little use out of it
seen this happen like
pre-designing charts up front we're
going to do this chart and that chart
and that chart
the charts end up being boring they
often get pushed to the back page
and then the semantics of presenting
predictions like 86 percent true those
are really complex
and subtle and it's the core of your
application and so you really want your
designer
and your data scientist collaborating
with on that
presentation from the beginning and
throughout the project and not like the
day
after you ship when people don't
understand what 86 true means
and so the core opportunity lies at the
intersection of data and design
so given all that how do we get back to
agility
so a statement of principles and then
tricks with code
so we want to set up an environment
where insights are repeatedly produced
where they're shared with the entire
team
where your application is interactive
from day zero
where your data model is consistent end
to end so that everyone can understand
the data
as it exists and work with it on the on
a reality-based
level as opposed to sort of mock-ups or
something like that
so that there's min you want minimal
impedance between layers so that anyone
can publish
you know up to that next layer with one
line of code
and then the insights that you generate
during this process is the palette for
what you ship hopefully until the
application pays for itself and more
so here's like a snowballing publishing
audience chart
you want to share the research at least
weekly
even if it's not done you can share
something intermediate
with the team and get that pushed out
into an app that way everyone
understands what the process is
so in this system of agile data science
we value the document over the relation
this is uh i used to live on a farm
in uh near outside athens in georgia
and um this is uh i guess after i moved
away i'm telling my dad to plant a cover
crop to improve the soil
because we have really thin red dirt
georgia red clay
and so um you can see this email it's a
simple document
you're familiar with it well this is the
raw data
of that and it's actually very similar
this is the relational representation of
an email this is the enron
emails from the large scandal and this
is the relational database schema for it
and this is my attempt to recreate a
document from that
and i didn't quite get it i had to use
on my sequelism
and uh i'm not the best person at sql
but i feel like this is harder than it
should be
and that if you're thinking in terms of
this you're really way off in terms of
connecting with the data
and so i would suggest that relational
data is a legacy format
up to some limit you can project uh
storage is really cheap
so you can just do the the you know
compute the result of the cubes and
and project that stuff to disk you don't
really have to do that on the fly
up to some reasonable limit of course um
you can duplicate joins into one big
record type even if you duplicate fields
that's okay again storage is really
cheap
so you can etl once on import not every
join
you don't do no joins but you do far
fewer
and then semi-structured documents
preserve the data's actual structure
just like it was there in the email and
also with new column
compressed formats and databases you
sort of uh
get the benefits of relational database
without actually storing your data in a
relational manner
column compression is a wonderful thing
so we value imperative languages over
declarative languages
in data science you fundamentally don't
know what you want to select
generally you sort of have this data and
you're not sure about it and you're
cleaning it and you're checking it out
as you go
and it's an inherently imperative
process so sql can work for this you can
do it stepwise
but it's not optimized for that process
and since 85 percent of your time the
statistic everybody makes up but
is spent munging as opposed to doing
cool math
having tools that are optimized for this
process is essential
which is in the process it's iterative
snowballing insight
there's also the opportunity with
imperative languages to self-optimize
and not rely on the magical query
planner
munching is like etl like reformatting
regular expressions to extract the
column you want from
the big blob of text that you get that
kind of thing
and so we value data flows over selects
this is a simple data flow
it's there's a tool called pig pen there
was research out of yahoo that turned
pig script into these charts
this one i've done manually but it's a
really great piece of research that
now some uh i think netflix has done a
newer
web app based version but this is how
you count the number of emails between
people
so you do a little bit of etl your
lowercase email addresses
you typically do etl as you actually
make the imperative queries
this is a longer example
so what i'm getting at is uh hive is
really popular because
it's like a sort of data warehouse thing
on hadoop you can
get at data that's not very structured
it's very powerful
but for doing data science i tend to
value pig over hive
for building analytics apps piggle eat
anything it's optimized for refining
data as opposed to consuming it
it's imperative and iterative it's data
flows that are sql-ish but not sql but
if you know sql it's easy to learn if
you if you know a programming language
there's code modular there's code
modularization
via macros and udfs in many languages
and with pig streaming you can stream
through any tool like r
for instance and what it allows us to do
is to prepare our data
on hadoop as it's going to be consumed
in our application
so it gives us that consistency of data
model throughout
that being said if you love hive use
hive
or shark or whatever and so there's a
requirement that's fairly absurd
at local host level on a sample versus
petabyte scale
you want to use the same tools
simplicity is scalability so we want the
highest level tools we can get
you can prepare a good sample with
documents it's very easy as opposed
to with relational data it's kind of
tricky because your joins will miss
use pig local mode illustrates a great
command that helps you generate example
data
even from a large data source it'll uh
sample and do some generation to satisfy
like if x is less than five it'll show
you four
and six and then four getting through
run the stuff locally get it working and
then run on the cluster and push it to
your
key value store and skip object
relational mapping
if the format the data is stored in is
not consistent with the format
that the designer ends up viewing and
consuming it in
then you're really not on the same page
and why encourage that with the system
that
is designed to map between multiple
abstractions
and so don't trust databases everything
is recreatable from hadoop at n equals
three
so you can trust data on hadoop it
doesn't go away
but your database may crash who cares
just rebuild it
and so uh pete warden kind of came up
with this concept of the data value
pyramid
where you start with just kind of
plumbing records through then you start
to make charts
then your charts become interactive and
link
between different kinds of entities
that's the report level
once you do that you're sort of prepared
to make predictions because you've
learned about your data
and the goal of making predictions is to
drive new actions that weren't possible
before and hopefully if you're
capitalist to
capture some of that value
and so the simplest level we'll start
with is uh just
plumbing records through which you want
to do like even before your first
meeting hopefully
so you want to document serialize your
events you can use protobufs thrifts
json i use avro because it's optimized
for large files
it has the schema on board which is very
convenient
so you can generate documents via
relational etl this is using pig to turn
the enron relational data into a
document
which is not much longer than the query
uh you can serialize events from streams
so uh in the book
um i tend to view that oh
one of the problems with pig is that you
have to manage the schema in your
scripts
and so um i
sort of view that as an asset in the
sense that
that's the place where the logic is
happening and so that makes the most
sense to prepare the schema
at that level that being said it can
certainly be tricky to
juggle a bunch of schemas and yeah
yes so you can save any relation into
avro format and then load it later
and the schema will be persisted you
mean like if you store using pig storage
and the schema is like gone
yeah so there's there's two approaches
avro is one and each catalog is another
to schema management
um they're both probably good but um you
do use avro storage there's a new one in
uh
pig pig 12. joe adler at linkedin
totally rewrote it
and so the old one is still in piggy
bank but the new one is a built-in
so try it out so in the book
we um download your gmail inbox and
serialize the emails as avro documents
and so that's a common pattern for for
generating documents
you might also etl logs
and so what you want to do is plumb
these atomic events like the lowest
level thing that you're operating on
in terms of data through to the browser
right away
um so this is a stack that is kind of
neat and cool
uh that i've used it's um
you know you serialize events to hadoop
then you've got hadoop project
which joins to mongodb
then you've got a node mongodb driver
and you can get json out to your web app
that being said i don't really care what
stack you use if you look at a bunch of
the blog posts
we've done like a dozen different stacks
or half dozen so all right step one
cat the avro serialized events this is
what an email looks like serializes an
avro which is the same way it looks
in raw data or on your screen
so we load the events in pig describe
the schema it's still consistent
now we illustrate events in pig so this
generates
some example data so you can see an
example which is helpful
next you publish the events to a
database in this case that database is
mongodb it's a one-liner if you have
data stored as avros to get it
into a mongodb relation there's this
little script that does this
and using the hadoop project your
data is just kind of there
it's kind of neat so now
log into and check your documents
they're still again consistent
now you want to publish those events to
the web this is a sinatra
app it's a ruby framework it's really
simple for building web apps
i also use python and flask a lot
pyramid seems to be the newer cooler kit
on the block
and so the json looks like this in a web
browser
so you'll notice that there's like a one
line one liner to transition the stack
so you can append to an avro file
and you can then load and store that
into mongodb
and then hitting mongodb with a mongodb
driver
get your data out to flask where you can
render html or json or whatever
so what's the point of doing that the
point is that now the designer the
product manager
the data scientists they can all
actually work on the same
they're on the same page and they can
all work against the same reality
so product managers tend to have
sometimes hair brained ideas especially
in the analytics field and so you can
now have grounded talks
about what is and isn't possible and
where you're at
you'll see how ugly the data is it's
probably worse than you think especially
if you're etling from a relational
database
the most common fields end up being like
null 0
n a that kind of thing relational
constraints aren't actually all they're
cut out to be
for many applications
but you have ton of work to do but you
can ship early and often and starts to
feel agile hopefully
so the next step is wrap the events that
you've published in your web app in
bootstrap
which is a project out of twitter
that gives you like a web 2.0 ish
container for your application without
doing any work
it allows engineers to make stuff that
isn't so distractingly ugly no one will
look at it
which is a real great it was like a
breakthrough for me when i
saw this project so this is a
json or or it's actually python a python
email record put inside a bootstrap
application box thing
so this is what it looks like once you
create some fields out of the
json structure it looks like kind of an
email browser
so then you can prepare a list of links
to
sorted events so you can make like an
inbox list
this is how you do that in pig you can
do this in mongodb if you add an index
and sort but you might not have that
ability if you were using like hbase or
something
so you might have to prepare pages of
sort of documents
depending on your scalability
requirements
so that looks like this when you present
an interface which looks a lot like your
inbox
there's a neat trick here the work that
you did to list emails can also be used
to display them if you do searches
and elasticsearch is a really cool
system built on top of lucine so really
it's kind of to me the hadoop of search
it's really easy to use
and so if you run like locally a copy of
elasticsearch
this is all the work you have to do to
make your emails searchable
which to me is out of sight um and then
you just use curl to
query it we do this in the book
you get incredible code reuse it's neat
all right so the next step since we
plumbed our records through is to create
simple charts
so this is an example of a data table
and a chart
so always start with an html table
because it always happens to me that
there are holes in the data
like there was a zero value and you
didn't actually project a zero
and it's empty and so your charts look
weird things like that always happen
so start with a table on general
principle
nvd3 is a library built on top of d3
there are several of these you can use
them or not the d3 examples are pretty
good and easy to extend themselves
make charts when we do that we're
aggregating by properties and displaying
them and that's the first step in entity
resolution
so we start extracting entities people
places topics
time series group documents by entities
rank and count
publish the top related things time
series
fill a page with charts
this is how you display the top any end
of anything in pig
it's fairly straightforward
this is how you could do a time series
of anything in pig
and so the stack ends up looking like
this you've got bulk storage
and hadoop so you're doing batch
processing in the back
then you've got a document or key value
store you're publishing to
uh then you've got your application
server client-side javascript
you might also have like a sub-real-time
processing layer
this could be like storm or it could be
queues and workers so the point of this
is that like
anyone can contribute because the schema
is consistent throughout
at any level according to their talent
right so the designer can mock something
up in html
and quickly get it plumbed with real
data or the web guy can do it in
javascript or you can do it in python or
vol
or in mongodb or in pig and everyone is
unconstrained and
able to be creative without sort of
having to wait on anyone else
so that's great everyone gets to
contribute new stuff
but we know that things scale most
easily when we push them back into
hadoop because hadoop scales
horizontally for
a lot of processes and so you
want to gyro or ticket them for uh
technical debt that they should be
shoved back
as you go so this is uh counting the
number of emails
how to do it in javascript in python
in mongodb look mapreduce even in
javascript is very lengthy
so never write mapreduce if you don't
have to use a higher level tool
and then pig right so the next level up
is reports
so once you start linking these pages
you get like related email addresses for
instance
you start to get a reporty feel to your
pages of charts
we start to extract entities from
properties we started to aggregate when
we
built charts in the last step each
entity gets its type own type of web
page
each unique entity gets its own web page
with a unique id
we can then link to entities as they
appear in our atomic records in this
case emails an email address can be a
link that kind of thing
so we link most related entities
together between types and within the
same
do more visualizations parameterize
these results with forms
what we're doing is creating interactive
ontologies of semi-structured data
a good way to start a user out in this
application other than search is to do a
tag cloud
but beware so we've abandoned relational
data
and now we uh may well filter the same
data in two different ways
during our data pipelines later try to
join them and we'll get key misses
so you'll go from this energy to that
one and it'll be 404 not found
it's a bummer when it happens so what
you want to do is when you're filtering
the base records try to
push those filters together into a
single file
that you then branch out from this is
something to keep in mind
so you're at the point now we can get
people clicking learn from them
take note google analytics what people
are actually using
the one of the nice things though about
this step is people will sort of tell
you things
that lead you to be able to generate
insight they'll be like oh well i really
want to see this or
i notice this or they'll help you clean
the data like oh this is totally screwed
up this field
and sometimes we'll even tell you how to
fix it
so now we've done a lot of work and
we're in a position to make predictions
and recommendations
so we've extracted entities their
properties and relationships our charts
show or our signal is rich
we've cleaned our data to make it more
presentable everyone has an intuitive
understanding of the data based on the
work we've done so far
and they got that by actually touching
the data and exploring it
so now we might start to think in
different perspectives like networks
time
series distributions natural language
processing
bayesian inference
this is a network bob knows sarah
sarah knows bob bob knows sarah bob
likes sarah but not too much
so this is the pig code to compute like
a weighted network from your inbox
this is a visualization of my inbox
this isn't a good visualization but i
put it in here because you should always
render a network for your project you
can make a network out of most anything
and you should render it in gephy which
is really easy to do
because it'll get your project funded
people like to go buy these and they're
like
is that a heart you know oh the data is
really complex
and and mysterious and they sort of
start to connect
with the processes that you actually do
but it's kind of a picture of it
and so you can get people on board this
way
so this is page rank and pig so you can
do social network analysis
i think we've already shown time series
you can like smooth sparse data
regress to find trends
there's a macro i did for tf idf term
frequency inverse document frequency
so it's like a one-liner to call that
process to work on documents at scale
pig's really neat this way
so this is uh just a simple word count
on the email i sent to my dad about
planning a cover crop
it's a wordle grass plant grass plant
grass
it works it's very simple but
there's also an example here for
leighton dritchlett allocation
this is a man called bayes who was
incredibly naive
bayesian inference is basically doing
pivot tables and then a little trick at
the end
so it's it's great as if you're not you
know that algorithmically advanced
um and it tends to perform surprisingly
well to the point that everyone is
always trying to beat it with
their sophisticated algorithms and often
don't
and so the literature is mostly
failing to beat naive bayes if you want
to look at it that way
but um it's definitely a great technique
to use
so let's look at doing something like
that to recreate
gmail suggested recipients this is me
emailing i had two editors this was the
first one
it tells me who i might want to include
so this is the code to reproduce that
feature in pig we'll step through it
so you get a count from two how many
people
i email so i emailed mike 28 times
then you get a co-occurrence count of
two and cc field
and then divide that by the total cent
to get a probability
of inclusion and then next
oh wait that's actually how this feature
works it's
you know google says simple algorithms
lots of data
and like this proves it
so now you can add predictions to your
reports the probability that my wife
will reply to one of my emails is 0.13
where she's going to see counseling but
no a lot of times i send her bills on
things
but so we want to enable new actions
so why doesn't kate reply to my emails
we have to do at this point some
business analysis
i may not be catching her at the right
time we have those time series so
you know email pops in at the top of
your inbox so if someone is emailing a
lot that would be the time to send it to
them
we could use that to optimize that
process my email's too long nobody
replies to my opuses they're just
embarrassed that i wrote
it are they meant to be replied to or am
i just forwarding existing emails
are they nice we could just send them an
analysis which is a bayesian thing
do i reply to her emails this was like a
men are from mars women are from venus
moment for me
it was deep um i don't think i do i
think i like oh i got that email yeah
and then do i see the wrong people the
probability that my wife will reply to
an email where i include my mom is zero
so um the book was up and uh on
o'reilly's open publishing system
and i've been blogging about the stack
with like hadoop hadoop
mongodb and then a simple web front end
and uh
a guy named michael baker in australia
started a company called packet loop and
he built a library called packet pig and
what he does he does full data capture
on your internet connection so he logs
every single packet
storage is cheap like you can generally
afford to do this even if you have a
pretty
thick pipe because it's almost always
not saturated
for most most connections so he logs
everything onto three or four terabyte
disks
and then he hits it with uh on s3 with
elastic mapreduce
he wrote a library to that hooks with
snort to do
uh intrusion detection and what he does
like
you may know that you're going to get
broken into tomorrow by the bug that
came out today
but you don't know if someone had that
and they broke in last week
well with his system you can go and scan
the old data with the new uh
signature and find out if they if they
broke in what they took
that kind of thing it's really cool and
so he follows this process he
refines the data in pig he is r and
streaming actually instead of python
but um so he scans it and it
it looks like this so this is like just
grouping by country this is
some attacks happen to be coming from
china
and so this is like way cooler than
anything i've shown
but the point is this is not that much
different um he had a designer
and a web developer work on this for you
know probably some weeks
and he was able to use this process to
get something that actually looks like
shippable
so that's it by the way i am
currently interviewing and so if you
want to hire me you think this stuff is
great and you want me around
you can totally do that
thanks
you